foreign
[Music]
thank you
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
the traitor of the house
so he uh posts on Broad Social
that he is declaring a standing order
for the House Republicans not to do
their job
which is not surprising that they're
that they're not going to do their job
not surprising one bit
I've been saying this and I I've been
telling you that Donald Trump is the one
that is going to decide when the
government will be shut down and when it
will be reopened this is what is going
to happen uh some this morning Matt
Gantz even threatening Kevin McCarthy
uh with the thing that Kevin McCarthy
fears the most which is that he will be
vacated from his seat as Speaker which
he's not really the speaker
one one one actual job description of
the speakers to be the leader of the
House of Representatives and Kevin
McCarthy is definitely not that he is a
[__] coward
not a leader he's a coward
now there is piles and piles and piles
of news out there
but this is one that we must keep
talking about and the reason why is
because it is so important in 2024
to get people out to the ballot and it's
so important to fight that fight at The
Ballot Box not just for the presidency
of the United States
but down the ticket
we need to make gains in the senate for
democracy
I mean speaking of the Senate news
a new joint uh chief chief of staff
joint chief of staff was
was placed yesterday and taubri Tommy
two two branches as I call him Tommy
tuberville's blockade
because he doesn't want women in the
military
and he doesn't want women to receive
health care and they're in the military
was broken
and they're going to get and Democrats
are going to continue to break this now
some are going to argue that maybe they
should have done this weeks ago but I
mean honestly Republic Democrats just
stood back and let Republicans dig their
own grave here
Republicans clearly don't give a [__]
about retired veteran or active duty
members of the military they don't give
a [__] I mean unless you're a [__]
Christian white nationalist
and then they'll protect you Tommy
tuberville will say [__] like well I
think I think they're Patriots
if they're white supremacist in the
military they must be Patriots
that's the only that's the only members
of the military that Tommy tuberville is
willing and Republicans are willing to
support
his white Christian nationalists I mean
frankly that's all they want in the
military I mean if you go if you go read
project 2025 that's all they want in the
United States government period
it's a 1930s solution to their cultural
War problem that they have
so there's news in the Senate
so we got to make Headway
in the Senate on the ballot in 2024. we
must make Headway in the house as well I
don't know if you noticed I don't know
if you noticed here lately the
government doesn't seem to be
functioning hmm now this is a feature
that the Republicans love that
government doesn't function because they
don't know how nor do they want to know
how nor do they actually want to do the
work of governing
it's very clear in some of these
interviews that are being given they're
like oh well well we can't
we can't keep the government open it's
just hopeless
well you are the majority and apparently
there's only about seven boats standing
in the way
manga Republicans that's what apparently
Matt Getz this morning is saying that
there's about seven boats standing in
the way of keeping the government open
I don't know it sounds
like uh Kevin McCarthy needs to step up
and be a leader here now also Matt Getz
says this morning I'm gonna show some of
these clips today
that if Kevin McCarthy makes a move to
work with Democrats because that's an
option that he has right he's got seven
votes there
Kevin McCarthy really could just be a
leader keep the government open like
he's supposed to do for the American
people
and he could go get the majority in the
house to vote for a CR to send to the
Senate to get to the president's desk
and boom we're done
not done it cans kick down the road
right
you know it's funny you know it's funny
is Republicans always [__] I mean they
[__] and [__] and [__]
when Democrats have control of the house
and a budget right and Democrats never
did get kicked can't budget and they got
all about spending blah you know what
you know the typical [__] that they
do
here they are in control of the house
they have the great opportunity
to have a I mean they've had since
January really honestly if you think
about it I mean [__] really December is
when they knew they were going to take
the house when they were going to be in
control they think they would have been
working on a budget maybe
now they were too busy doing podcasts
and going down flying down to Mar-A-Lago
and getting their Cheeto dust knee pads
on
and and concentrating fully on their
Hunter hog syndrome
whoosh
yesterday they had the um
the 100 by non-lamped up
Committee hearing when they were asking
Merrick Garland questions
you notice that I said that yesterday
did you notice I I've been watching more
and more Clips they literally have
abandoned the word laptop
do you notice then
isn't that [__] something God damn
and they aren't really saying pro-life
anymore either
you know what I'm saying they don't even
and they don't like the word
conservative anymore either we really
ruin these [__] words for him you
notice that you see how that works
you see then
this this is how it actually works with
narrative and messaging when you destroy
when you destroy something for them
because I mean they went on for years
laptop laptop laptop laptop laptop
laptop not the [__] laptop
and they they can't even they can't even
they can't even muster up enough courage
to work out the word in a Committee
hearing you know what I said that was
astonishing to me
because we ruined the word for them we
ruined that narrative and that messaging
and the reason why is not us their
stupidity ruined it for him we just
pointed out the [__] stupidity right
we just pointed it out
and the entire country is like yeah that
was really dumb because remember oh my
God Matt Getz set in a [__] hearing
and he had a thumb drive he's like I
want to submit this as evidence it's the
contents of Hunter Biden's laptop it'll
make Joe Biden resign and tremble get
the king in the crown of the United
States at Trump or whatever the [__] he
said right
it was supposed to be the best the best
evidence that we had
of why Donald Trump should be Crown King
of the United States
they told us right on and on and on it
went in the [__] comment section
they'd post pictures remember they
[__] put the whole thing online the
whole fake ass hard drive they put that
[__] online
and now they don't even bring it up
what the f why is that
is there something about the lie about
the laptop is the reason why they won't
even say the word laptop
it's because of our our messaging and
our narrative
the pro-democracy Coalition they
basically call [__] on them
and they dug in man they were like you
know what yeah we're gonna [__] it we're
gonna run on the laptop thing in 2022
it's gonna be awesome
their the American people are gonna
elect us so we can so we can get Hunter
Biden's laptop out in the open in the
country will be better we'll have lower
gas prices inflation will go down Joe
Biden will resign and we'll have
President King Trump
I I don't I mean that's literally kind
of how they
[__] sold it right
they sold the hunter Biden's laptop as
the worst thing ever in the history of
America
now they can't even muster up the word
say it out loud
it's the same reason why the left
shouldn't say Universal
same thing same [__] thing
same same
they ruined the word Universal they
ruined it don't ever say that ever
when you're talking about policy ever
never say that word ever
just like they're not gonna say the word
laptop because we [__] ruined it
good
know the power of messaging know the
power of of information
know the power of propaganda for crying
out loud a lot of people get really
really um uneasy when I say the word
propaganda
as if we should use it as a weapon
against
the Nazi propaganda coming from the
Republican party and we should
that's right we should use pro-democracy
propaganda
to combat and to weaponize it against
the Nazi propaganda coming out of the
Republican Party
I mean you know it might feel like oh my
God ah that word
it works it [__] works
I mean was there a lot of salacious [__]
on the laptop of course there was was it
was there probably some evidence of
crime on Hunter Biden's laptop maybe I
don't know
I don't know
I mean they [__] stole it from him so
that's probably a [__] crime
speaking
speaking of crime and Rudy Giuliani
stealing Hunter Biden's laptop
he was groping on Cassie Hudson Cassidy
Hutchinson oh my God who oh man who
could have thought that that's coming
out of nowhere that's so surprising that
Rudy Giuliani would molest someone
really this is I mean you know I get why
now
why now Cassidy Hutchinson has to say
this because it really wasn't
relevant for the January 6 select
hearing I think that was really the
question like why the [__] didn't we
know this
when because it happened on January 6th
so like he's like yeah cool baby cool
come here let me honk your Hooters I
don't know maybe maybe he you know
should have took Lauren bobert to a
musical and it would have been
consensual at that point but apparently
this groping was non-consensual
of Cassidy Hutchison on January 6th
dude was dude was horny on January 6.
what does that tell you about Rudy
giuliani's mindset
woo holy moly
I mean there's nothing like to get you
worked up and get you all hard and horny
and hot then a coup attempt right am I
right am I right or am I right
oh my God but it's not surprising
and really honestly Rudy giuliani's
going on any [__] Trader News Network
that'll let him come on and go ahead
and deny any of these allegations
that I had my hands down my pants in
that movie no no no that not that one
this is the Cassidy Hutchinson one mayor
oh yeah sorry I had a little too much
Scotch today
so it's not surprising that Rudy
Giuliani did that so speaking of crimes
uh we all know Rudy Giuliani was the
organizer to steal 100 mines lamped up
his hard drive a copy of his hard drive
and somehow it just ended up
in some computer shop in Delaware and
then Rudy somehow knew it was there and
he went and got it I wonder I wonder if
it was like planted
and I don't know telling how much
information that was placed on this
lamped up
and I know I'm saying the word laptop a
lot folks you should be saying it a lot
too you should be asking people about it
everywhere that you can everywhere what
happened on everybody's laptop where the
[__] what the [__] happened to Hunter
Biden's laptop
wasn't that supposed to be the thing
that saved our country huh wasn't it
why have Republicans abandoned Hunter by
oh that's right because it doesn't exist
it's all [__] just like their stupid
[__] just like their stupid ass
claims of bribery from China yeah vagina
yo mating chick money from vagina
through Hunter bidens hog he was getting
paid
for someone
to play with this hog in a Beetlejuice
musical oh wait that was someone
different
always with these people always
why do you think it's so easy to mock
them why do you think it's so easy to
knock them down a pig
that's why the media is failing so
[__] spectacularly Jesus Christ you
people can't even knock them down a peg
a little bit [__] me
uh for for two days we talked about John
fetterman's hoodie speaking that John
fetterman's like hey [__] I'll put a
suit on as long as if you guys keep the
government open do that
you keep the government open I'll put a
[__] suit on
I think that's so many words but
literally that's his words
you know what and again I I don't like
to talk about
um you know sitting politicians as if we
should you know look up to them or think
that there's some sort of have super
powers or something but really honestly
this brand of Democrats this brand of
liberalism of the in the John fetterman
Universe the John fetterman brand which
I I you know I'm not saying I'm taking
credit I'm just saying that his brand my
brand the other other brands out there
this new brand that's coming up with
Democrats does it take [__] [__] off
nobody
Eric swallowing yesterday I showed the
clip where he absolutely [__] watched
Jim Jordan up and dunks him in the chat
trash
calling Jim Jordan out right there right
there live on his hypocrisy
and and again we should not take the
shovel out of their hands when they're
digging their political grave so if
Kevin McCarthy wants to be a coward and
he doesn't want to do the thing which is
that leadership
if that's what he wants to do and shut
down the government fine that's what
they were gonna do anyways
damage their plan was to plan the entire
time
I mean anytime they get power they abuse
the [__] out of it don't you know that
and it doesn't have to just be in the
House of Representatives in the United
States government or in the senate or in
the White House
I mean you see it in Tennessee in the
state house in Tennessee you see it in
red States all around the country
Florida with the governor Ron I'm I'm
gonna kill someone without execute
someone without due process because of
the color of their skin
DeSantis
net Florida fascist
and then you got Greg Abbott who wants
to cut up babies at the border with
razor wire I mean what what do you want
from me I'm just telling you what the
[__] is happening
oh they're yelling and screaming about
Venezuelans oh [__] me oh my God
Venezuelans are pouring across the
border
hmm
you know what's funny about that is 9
000 of them have been detained
just recently
the Biden Administration is working hard
to figure out why they're coming and
then trying to figure out how to how to
manage it like leaders would [__] do
the Republican solution is desantis's
solution just shoot him just kill them
just ask you just you know genocide type
[__] you know what I mean don't ask
questions just shoot them
no due process of law forget the [__]
Constitution we don't need the
Constitution we don't need Law and Order
it's not a thing especially with
Republicans especially with fascists
Nazi Nazi Republicans
don't need it don't need it why do you
need government anyways you don't need
government you just need a few a few
[__] boys they're on the border with
some guns and you just start you know
target practice what do you need
government for you don't need to keep
the government open to do these things
to secure our border you don't need you
don't need to appoint people to military
positions who needs National Security
who needs that huh
I mean Jesus Christ who needs all this
stuff anyways that we have you know
roads Bridges Medicare Medicaid you know
hospitals libraries Public Schools
you know like meat inspections food
inspect who the [__] needs that [__]
anyways right am I right am I right who
gives a [__] about all that stuff that
our United States government does not
including Transportation oh my God who
the [__] needs transportation in this
country
do we really need this I mean really
come on
are these things that the American
people want and need
the way of life that we've built with
our government huh really is it
of course I'm
just playing a republican there for a
minute
that and that's what it feels like when
they say this [__] but it's not what
they say it's not what they actually
believe because when when you go out and
you talk to these these [__]
brainless idiots
who had this delusion of what the
government is and what it isn't
and how our country operates and why it
operates the way it operates
when you go talk to these brainless
idiots they they want you to keep your
government hands off their Medicaid and
government hands off their Medicare
and they you don't they don't want
socialism
they don't like socialism
for other people themselves love it they
[__] love socialism for themselves oh
my God I couldn't tell you how much rule
Farmers love them some [__] socialism
hell they're grandpappy's grandpappy was
the original [__] socialist in this
country
they just don't want other people right
I want my rich white welfare
so that way you don't get your poor
Brown welfare okay okay got it
but that's the attitude
in the house with Republicans they don't
give a [__]
about their constituents they don't care
about this country they don't give a
[__] about our national security they
don't give a [__] about the Border they
don't give a [__] about any of that
stuff
alls they care about is money and power
period that's it as long as they have
money and power they can give a [__]
less about anything else they could care
less about your whining about [__]
Public Schools they give a [__] less
about you whining because there's no
hospital they got hospitals they got
great health care frankly and [__] they
live next to a hospital anyways
what why why are they concerned that you
need a hospital or you need libraries or
you need Public Schools [__] and what
why why do you need why do you need
streets and and electricity
really like in Texas what do you need
electricity for in Texas huh and then
Broadband are you kidding me you whiny
little [__] you want Broadband God
damn we just got to do everything for
ourselves don't we [__]
how dare you be so needy America
it's as if they don't have any clue how
our economy is built how our economy
runs how the country runs runs
they have no [__] clue well they do
they just don't give a [__]
and it's clear because if if Kevin
McCarthy really gave a [__] what he
would be doing is being a leader right
now
and he would go to the 1015 manga caucus
that is that is threatening him with his
job
if he doesn't shut down the government
because that's what they're doing
they're like hey if you don't do your
job or or if you do your job if you do
your job we're gonna take it away from
you literally that's what they're saying
if Kevin McCarthy does his job as
Speaker of the House they are going to
vacate his seat now you're gonna they're
gonna fire him if he does his job
you sir are supposed to not do your job
that's what republicanism is about okay
but think about that that's literally
what is happening right now as we as we
[__] sit here and you're listening
the Republicans are out telling
reporters if Kevin McCarthy does his job
then we'll fire him
the American people need to know and and
they're gonna know it folks they're
gonna know it I mean they're gonna try
all kinds of tactics one of the tactics
is going to be it's covered lockdowns
I'm telling you they're going to be
saying it
I mean it's September 21st so we got you
know a couple weeks and then there will
be a clip from Trader TV some some
Trader TV News Network that I will play
here and I said see here I'll show you
it's golden lockdowns you're biting it's
all Biden's fault cause the kovid
in the vaccine or whatever I don't know
they'll come up with some stupid [__]
but it'll be about Kobe lockdowns it
won't be government shutdown
and it won't be their fault definitely
be Brandon's fault right
but that's literally what the house
Republican Maga caucus is saying
if Kevin McCarthy does his job if you do
your job we will [__] fire you
how much sense does that make
doesn't make any sense it's not supposed
to make sense though and the reason why
is because Kevin McCarthy isn't actually
the speaker that's what I want you to
understand Kevin McCarthy is not that he
holds the office he has the title he
like he likes got his [__] in the in the
actual physical Office of the speaker
but he's not the Speaker of the House
Donald Trump is the Speaker of the House
he controls Kevin McCarthy because he
controls the vote
because he's got his little sheep and
his lackeys and his traitors
in the House of Representatives
and they can force Kevin McCarthy to do
just about anything they want
now he could be a leader and he could
tell them I mean he literally could come
out to a microphone today and say you
can [__] off
you either you got 24 hours you got 24
hours to get on a CR with Republicans or
I'm gonna go to the Democrats and you're
not gonna like that CR
you're not gonna like that [__] because
I'm gonna need votes
and we're gonna whatever the [__] we
need to do to keep the government open
I'll go to Democrats if he did that he
went out front of a microphone
maybe maybe I'd have some respect for
him probably not but maybe just make
just maybe maybe just maybe
I would think he's not such a coward but
he is so he's not going to do that
because he knows he knows
that Donald Trump will remove him as
speaker if he does that
now we'll have a CR the government would
be open but then Kevin McCarthy won't be
speaker and they won't actually have a
speaker
because that's the other thing here if
you think about it if they vacate the
seat of speaker who in the [__] are they
going to get to be speaker of the house
do you remember the last time a speaker
of the house voluntarily left
I talked about it the other day John
Boehner John Boehner's like I had enough
of you [__] lunatics I'm done I'm not
gonna be a speaker anymore and he lamb
and he he pretty much said that I mean
not exact words but that was the
the overall gist of it
and you remember they didn't have anyone
because Kevin McCarthy at the time uh
proved to be a dumb [__] because
he couldn't keep his mouth shut about
Hillary Clinton and Benghazi and why
they actually had a Benghazi committee
it wasn't to get to the truth it was
just a you know weaponized government
against Hillary Clinton in her campaign
like they claim is happening with Trump
okay that's literally what Kevin
McCarthy said is well we weaponized the
government with the Benghazi committee
we spent tons of government money and
resources to damage her campaign
literally that's what they did
did it work I don't know you know you
know we don't we don't have to Hash that
out
but that's why Kevin McCarthy couldn't
be speaker at that time
because he looked like a [__] idiot
saying that [__] out loud now oh man you
have to say that stuff out loud now you
have to you have to be the stupid of the
stupid to make it in the Republican
party today
I mean just look no further than George
Santos or Jim Jordan or James Comer who
can't [__] scratch up enough evidence
to back their claims
but think about it who in the [__]
if they vacate the seat who are they
going to put as Speaker there won't be a
speaker
can you imagine that
maybe our government shutdown and we
don't have a speaker of the house that's
how [__] that's how horrible they are
at governing because they don't want to
govern and so why why would you elect
folks that don't want to govern well you
would if you wanted to protect
your criminal in Chief right I mean
because that's what this is all about
anyways when he tweeted he or he he post
on fraud social
yesterday his orders that you will shut
down the government I said so
and the reason why is to protect me
because he thinks some [__]
convoluted way
that if the government shuts down then
it will get rid of his prosecutions
which it won't
I mean it might slow him down a bit
it'll definitely slow him down a bit
you know that right
yep apartment just part of the federal
government they need to be funded too
now some of that funding is going to
stay but some of it's not
it'll slow it'll slow court dockets down
yep sure will
oh Tony he'll definitely go to trial
he's definitely gonna go at every single
trial
oh there goes the Manhattan D.A trial
hmm
oh man looks like the Georgia trial
isn't gonna get that quick and fast and
in a hurry
Canon's definitely going to get canned
down the road hmm
that only leaves one left I guess
and it ain't gonna happen on March 4th
now
is it do you think
I'm glad you tune in every single
weekday when we hash out these issues
here on the Tony Michaels podcast for
two full hours noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific on YouTube
Facebook and twitch make sure you go to
the Tony michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com hit subscribe at the top
you're not going to want to miss a
single notification that I send you
because I send you the link to the show
every single day so you can watch it you
can also support the show by buying me a
shot kind of a fun way to support the
show or if you want to get a message in
on the screen hit the venmo Super Chat
make sure you give me your handle and
the platform you're on so I can give you
proper credit uh when I bring your
comment up on the screen and then if you
want to support me on patreon you can do
that as well I also want to thank the
audience here
for the support that you have given to
the library of democracy YouTube channel
there's going to be a lot of things
happening over there we got over a
thousand yesterday so thank you so so
very much I think we're almost to 1200
by now it's getting close to 1200. again
we're over 1100 on our way to 1200 over
there on the library of democracy so I
really appreciate all the help that you
gave there let me give you that that
link one more time to the library of
democracy uh you're not again you're not
going to want to
be without this on your subscribe list
oh that's not the one I want you're not
going to want to be without this on your
subscribe list
um going forward you're going to want to
watch all these videos it's going to
give you just little Key Parts
of how to engage in your democracy
because our our democracy is under
attack from disinformation right-wing
agendas and politicians who believe we
should suspend the Constitution yes
they said that and on the channel of the
library democracy you'll find
information on how to find tools the
information to do whatever you can
wherever you can to take actionable
steps towards doing your part in this
fight
and it's presented by a real life
librarian literally a real librarian
is presenting this information to you so
don't forget to go and subscribe to the
library of democracy everyone stick
around on the break go go subscribe but
stick around come back come back we're
gonna show some clips
uh right after this break
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
well it was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenteous lamb gems
skull
near run out daddy light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag now the live love and blue one in
your absence I discovered a rash on my
neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
come [__] a [__] a [__] em
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
happy birthday to you Polly 77 on Twitch
happy birthday late birthday
[Music]
yesterday happy happy birthday
happy birthday to you paulie77 on Twitch
thanks for joining us here at the Tony
Michaels podcast two full hours every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
if you want to get in on the fun you're
going to want to go to the Tony
michaels.com hit the Subscribe button at
the top of the page I'll send you
notifications every single day and every
single time we have a new link for a new
episode and you can find that episode at
the top of the page every single day
it's right there
and then every once in a while the
Sunday rants for patreon pop up there
you can buy me a shot it's a fun way to
support the show I could not keep this
microphone on without you you are the
reason why this microphone stays hot and
I stay yelling into it
and I'm not I'm not supported by any
Corporation Soros doesn't send me a
check he sends Vivek checks but he
doesn't send me checks I don't know I
don't have to tell you it's kind of
weird that Vivek Rama salami takes uh
Soros checks but I don't get any but
that's just the way it is so what am I
supposed to do I'm supposed
to tell you the real raw truth keep you
in a place where you can find that
cathartic release that you need for this
stupidity then our politics has become
with the House of Representatives just
like we're going to do today we're going
to do some cathartic release here we're
going to make fun and mock these idiots
because that's what they are
because they do not want to govern they
refuse to govern and so keep the mic on
keep the support going rather you buy a
shot you do a venmo super chat if you
want me to get your message up on screen
uh you can go to patreon and join
patreon you can pay by the year now by
the way and you can also just throw some
money in the tip jar if you if you want
to just support the show that way
another way to support the show for free
for free it gives monetary support for
the show for free
this link right here it says link Amazon
and twitch
it's a great opportunity if you have an
Amazon Prime account you just go to
twitch.tv slash the Tony Michaels link
your Amazon Prime account to your Twitch
account you get one free subscription
with Amazon gaming right you get one
free subscription with Amazon gaming
and you can give the show that
subscription on Twitch and it gives us a
couple bucks a month like literally it's
like two dollars and eight cents or
something like that I've done the map
before I can't believe that's how that's
how less of the five dollars that we get
but that's the truth
but it's free it doesn't cost you a
single dime if you're an Amazon Prime
user now you also have to renew
the subscription every single month to
make sure that we get the Amazon Prime
money that you send us so make sure that
you're going into twitch and renewing it
you might want to set an alarm
like if you have to go in and renew it
just set an alarm on your phone that way
you know to renew it the next time the
next month and so many people go and
renew it every single month and you can
watch over there on Twitch too and
you're probably going to want to go at
least follow on Twitch because it's free
to follow it didn't cost you anything to
follow
it's just a subscription thing with the
with the monetary Support over there
it's free when you use Amazon to support
us over there with the with the
subscription but you're going to want to
go follow the twitch because in October
I don't know if you know this in October
we're gonna do a karaoke event
I think it's October 15th it's the third
Sunday in October and we're going to air
it on Twitch and Discord but twitch and
if you want to get in on the Discord do
that too I'll put the link there in the
in the chat so you guys can do that
you're definitely going to want to
follow those channels if you want to get
in on that and if you're on patreon
for the karaoke what you'll be able to
do is you'll be able to sign up
to appear with me on screen during the
karaoke event on Sunday October 15th so
don't forget if you're on patreon to be
watching for the sign up and go join the
patreon just go to the Tony michaels.com
and you'll find the patreon link right
there at the top so thank you for all
your support again it's the only way I
keep this microphone running and this
microphone on and yelling and screaming
to give you the cathartic release that
you need every single weekday for two
full hours now let's get into some of
this cathartic release
yeah because the stupidity is abounding
oh it's abundant this morning the
absolute stupidity now I got a few Clips
yesterday and again there's just clip
after clip after clip after clip of
stupidity I want to start with uh some
of the stupidity that the Department of
Transportation secretary Pete bootage
ran into yesterday from a Republican
representative from California
oh my God I cannot believe that Pete
butterjudge has to give a kindergarten
class
in a congressional hearing like this
literally like he has to teach
Republicans
kindergarten curriculum it's [__]
wild stuff
but they are Republicans so what are we
supposed to do here let me let me show
you here uh
uh la mofla
I don't know I don't know who the [__]
this clown is he's some Republican so
that shouldn't be surprising to you at
all but let's listen to How what he
thinks client he thinks climate change
is autumn
winter spring and fall he thinks climate
change is the seasons
I'm not kidding you it's weird stuff but
let's watch who wants those nobody wants
these electric vehicles unless you're an
elite that can afford them people in my
district stores I don't want them so
keep going why are we doing this is it
over CO2 yeah oh oh that by the way by
the way I I want to tell you that people
in his district don't want these things
is all [__]
that's all [__] really honestly
probably the reason why people can't
have EVS in his district is because he
as a representative of his constituents
is probably preventing the
infrastructure being placed so they can
have EVS this is really [__] dumb and
Pete butterjudge does a good job of
pointing it out here but this idea that
Americans don't want EBS is really
[__] stupid the reason why Americans
can't have EVS in some parts of the
country is because there is an
infrastructure there that's what the
administration is saying is saying hey
EVS are coming these car manufacturers
are not holding off on EVS anymore that
is what they're going to manufacture the
private the private sector okay not not
the [__] government the private
sector is going to move on this market
and the reason why is because I don't
know we're tired of giving all of our
[__] money and profit to oil
companies and Americans are sick of
having to fill up their [__] gas tank
right now is oh EVS the best solution
for this I mean I guess that's debatable
right like you could sit sit down and
have a real debate
a real debate or rather EVS are actually
going to leave a less of a footprint
than than
gasoline-powered vehicles or diesel just
fossil fuel powered vehicles for that
matter you could probably have that
debate now it's not going to be much of
a debate because in the long run the EV
is going to win and the reason why is
because once the infrastructure is built
on the back of renewable energy which we
have the capability and the technology
to do literally literally every single
in-cell Republican idiot on the internet
those crypto Bros they [__] love them
some Elon Musk
and Elon Musk honestly the one thing
that Tesla does well the one thing they
do well which I think they'll actually
continue to do well if you want to know
the honest truth
is to provide the small infrastructure
to people who want to own EVS
Tesla is really good about putting
renewable energy panels on the top of
houses and charging their EV right there
at their house okay they're really good
at it
because they had to have that
to have EVS in the market like you had
to have some infrastructure well you if
you didn't have mass infrastructure you
could create micro infrastructure
so they're really getting they're shitty
at making and making [__] Vehicles
they catch on fire and [__] so they're
really [__] bad at that okay like
Tesla is not figured out how to not have
their cars catch on fire which is kind
of a problem you know when you're
selling to people I want to kind of
drive them around and [__] but anyways I
digress from that
but this bonehead thinks that the reason
why no one wants EV Vehicles is is
because they're not manly enough I'm not
really understanding why the [__] he
thinks other than he want he he gets big
money from Big Oil
why he [__] thinks
that people don't want EV vehicles but
let's listen yeah we're doing it for
three reasons
even though the EV Revolution is going
to happen anyway oh it's a revolution I
would love to be able to answer your
question yeah okay even though we think
that transition is happening in the
automotive sector no matter what there
are three things that we think are not
guaranteed
will it happen quickly enough to
materially help with climate change
will it happen on Equitable terms that
are available to people who aren't
wealthy
if I could just please finish let's
drill on the climate let's finish
about CO2 isn't it what percent of the
atmosphere is CO2 that we're chasing
here
I'm sorry what percent of the atmosphere
is CO2 that we're chasing here because
we talked about climate change I I don't
know the percentage of atmospheric gases
you don't know the percent of that too
what I can tell you is that climate
change is real okay so climate change is
real right okay
remember people to judge believes
the climate change is real
let's keep that fact in your mind for a
second when you hear what this bonehead
says
in the next breath
we got to do something about it yeah sir
so sorry this one's called Autumn right
now so yeah I'm sorry I couldn't make
out what you said sir this climate
change right now is called Autumn yes
yeah that's that's the seasons changing
which respectively is not the same thing
as the climate changing
ha
ridiculous
that the secretary of the Department of
Transportation has to go to a Committee
hearing and explain
to a grown ass man
to a grown ass man who is a elected
official a [__] United States
Congressman for crying out loud explain
to him
that the daily weather
and the seasons changing
is not climate changing it's [__]
wild stuff when they're like ah it's
really cold outside today so there's no
way there's there's climate change
and these [__] don't know the
difference between weather seasons and
climate
so people the judge has to give a
kindergarten lesson to this idiot
and he called it Autumn you know I'm I'm
not you know I'm not going to bash
um too many people I'm okay I'm going to
I'm going to mock him for saying Autumn
most most people say fall it's the fall
you know because it's America
it's [__] elitist Colts fall Autumn
come on man
and no one calls it Autumn I'm just
saying I'm just saying no one calls it
Autumn Maybe I'm Wrong
Maybe Maybe I'm Wrong maybe wrong but in
America we call it fall the spring the
summer the fall and that cold ass winter
[Laughter]
Stargell says Autumn Falls same thing
yeah I know it's the same thing I'm just
just pointing out
that the congressman from California who
claims that EVS are elitist is using the
word Autumn instead of fall just I'm
just kind of doing that little thing
there
oh my God but he doesn't he doesn't want
his constituents to have access to EVs
and the reason why this [__]
chucklehead Republican does not want his
constituents to have access to EVS or
the infrastructure is because it will
hurt his big money Big Oil corporate
donors
it'll hurt him
and Pete Buddha judge is only pointing
out facts here that hey the Eevee
Revolution and this guy's oh hope
Revolution hey you caught her I mean
what I mean whatever you want to call it
man whatever [__] tag you want to put
on it the market wants to like those
nobody wants these electric vehicles
unless you're an elite that can afford
to yes they do they do want them
and just because you buy an EV doesn't
mean you're an elite and by the way
by the way
it it is it is [__] astounding
astounding that these [__] idiots
don't know how much a goddamn gasoline
vehicle cost
have you went and looked at how much a
pickup truck cost
have you seen that even a used pic you
can't find a good used pickup truck for
less than fifteen thousand dollars in
this country
are you kidding me and you're and you're
and I'm talking about a used pickup
truck that's got a hundred thousand
miles on it
by day standards that's a 15 000 used
vehicle because it takes gasoline I
guess I mean they're so much better and
there's so much less Elite aren't they
[__] out of here with this nonsense
you gotta go take out a goddamn mortgage
from a bank to buy a used truck with a
hundred thousand miles on it
and then you got to put [__] gasoline
in it right am I right or am I right I
mean it make a pretty yard ornament I
guess if you wanted to get a a 10-year
mortgage on a used pickup truck to make
it a yard ornament I mean that'd be
great
that'd be great right
[__] out of here with this nonsense
about well well people don't want EVS
because they're too expensive
well fix the gas problem then that
wasn't that what wasn't that what we
were supposed to elect Republicans to do
in 2022 anyways was to fix the gas
remember that they were like gasoline is
out of control Joe Biden
we're gonna stop Joe Biden from Raising
gas prices
well you can't even keep the [__]
government open
what what makes you makes us think that
we're gonna let you entrust you that you
can lower gas prices which you if you
wanted to lower gas prices then you
would I don't know probably support the
infrastructure and the advancement of
electric vehicles in this country which
would probably lower the demand of
gasoline
how in the [__] don't these people who
claim to be free market capitalists know
how any of this [__] works
how how is it even [__] possible that
these boneheads run around in this
country talking about free market and
capitalism and all this [__]
speaking out against workers telling
workers you're going to be fired if you
strike if you want more pay [__] you
we'll fire your dumb ass and Republicans
presidential candidates you said in
United States senators
are in fact saying [__] you they should
fire them if they if they want more
money you want more money from rich
people why don't you just be rich
already would you
Jesus you Poor's it even smells like the
pores around here in these in these in
these protests and these these these
union strikes it smells like the pores I
I don't know how they got to this point
but they don't even know
that one of the reasons why the auto
market is moving towards EVS is to lower
the demand for fossil fuels
because it's getting out of control
right and they see see like if I was a
car company right and I made vehicles
and I was like you know what if we keep
making these vehicles like this
eventually No One's Gonna buy them
that seems like a let's just keep doing
that because Republicans want us to and
oil companies want us to we'll just you
know we'll go into into a space where
we're non-existent because someone's
gonna someone's gonna build EVS
right whether it's Ford Chevrolet
Chrysler
Honda Toyota Hyundai someone in the
American Market is gonna build EVS a
whole lot better than Tesla ones that
don't catch on [__] fire
hopefully
if they're going to build the EVS
and it's as the infrastructure gets
better and better and better
there's going to be more EVS on the
market
and there's gonna be more people using
EBS which is going to lower the demand
for oil and gas for vehicles in this
country
it's kind of the [__] point I mean
not only to lower the gas prices all
right but also not rely on fossil fuels
and I don't know kill our [__]
environment
why in the [__] is it that conservatives
right
you know what the word conserve means
right if you don't I'll give you a few
seconds you can go Google that [__] or
dust off your dictionary pull it off
yourself dust it off you can look up the
word conserve
you would think that conservatives would
want to have conservation
of our country and of our resources now
no that's because they're not actually
conservative I didn't know if you knew
that
oh speaking of people who don't want to
do their [__] jobs here is the
here's a couple House Republicans chip
Roy you know this [__] racist who
love oh man chip Roy loves loves him
some lynching do you remember that yeah
that chip really and then there's that
representative bird [__] remember bird
[__] where he's like oh we just listen
uh we just got a problem in this country
with the children being killed in
elementary skills and you're just not a
goddamn thing we can do about it I mean
my suggestion is if you don't want your
children to be murdered in elementary
schools is you should you should
homeschool them that's what we do oh
well thanks for the help there Senator
bird [__] that guy and then Matt gatz
Matt gatz Matt the guy who was making
public venmo payments for drugs and
prostitutes underage prostitutes
trafficking them across state lines
and that guy
oh they man they got some wonderful
points to make here let's listen
with all the respect to my served
colleagues let them go explain why they
don't support that it's completely
inexplicable
um and uh I think it's indefensible
so you know here we said so now we got
to go try to figure out how to move the
ball forward but we had agreement in
good faith with people across the
conference the speaker's job be in Peril
if you relies on Democrats
it wouldn't be a good move if speaker
McCarthy relies on Democrats to pass a
continuing resolution uh I would call
the capital moving truck to his office
pretty soon because my expectation would
be he'd be out of the speaker's office
quite promptly I would never like to see
a shutdown but uh if that's where it's
going that's where it's going oh oh
here's here's Senator birdshit I mean
excuse me representative Tim birdshit
and that how you say that and then how
you say his name there let me show you
and now you say his name here Tim bird
[__]
I don't know seems appropriate he's got
the same he's got the same attitude
towards keeping the government open as
he does protecting children in schools
and not having them slaughtered right
he's like oh well it just ain't goddamn
thing we can do it's not like I'm
elected official or anything it ain't
like I'm elected to do a job it ain't
like I'm elected to govern and represent
constituents see what I'm elected is to
come here and represent the the interest
of my corporate donors and my rich
donors that's what I'm here to do and
that's what we're going to do so
whatever it takes
which is nothing let's continue with
bird [__]
and that last comment something that has
been echoed up and down the line about
the growing expectation that a shutdown
will happen here how they get out of it
remains to be seen because oh my God oh
my God do you do you see what I mean
about the media you see what I mean
about this this [__] now he's a
great reporter
he's a great reporter he's running
around the capital all the time sticking
microphones in these people's faces
but here he is
oh well it looks like maybe just in uh
maybe no they're going listen they're
going to shut the government down
okay
just look at the [__] facts and it
will lead you to what is going to happen
it's not complicated to see it it is not
Kevin McCarthy cannot and will not seek
Democrats
to make sure that there is a stop Gap or
a CR by October 1st
so if that is the case if Kevin McCarthy
cannot
I mean he could but he's a coward so he
cannot because of his cowardice he
cannot seek to work with Democrats to
get a CR or a stopgap measure to give
them more time to get ACR he cannot do
that and the reason why he cannot is
because they will vacate his seat
and there are there are seven to ten
votes that will not walk with him and
they will vacate his seat
which means there is no speaker which
means there is no build to the floor
which means there is no stop gap which
means there is no CR
got it
now
let's go on the other side of things
it doesn't appear
that Republican caucus wants to keep the
government they want to close it folks I
don't know if you've been listening to
right wing talk or watching these
[__] accounts
on on Twitter just on Twitter just on
Twitter
but all you don't have to go further
than the look and I know it's difficult
to go look at his page but Charlie Kirk
is showing he's telling you
what they're going to do and he says it
in almost every [__] tweet
almost everyone he's like shut it down
Hold the Line shut it down
stop stop funding the war in Ukraine we
want Putin to win we want Putin to take
Ukraine
kill people at the border kid is shoot
him the DeSantis 1930 solution for
anyone across the border just execute
them without due process law shut down
the government as if Charlie Kirk
doesn't know if you shut down the
government it's actually going to cause
more problems at the border who the [__]
do you think controls the [__] border
besides the [__] federal government
Charles
but that's what they are they are they
are [__] telling everyone in their
universe that the government must be
shut down because they got to protect
Trump
from prosecution they got they gotta
[__] make sure that they're that
they're executing people at the border
like the scientists once they gotta make
sure they we oh man we got to make sure
that there's no funding for hospitals
Schools rule rule Broadband up and then
definitely definitely don't want air
traffic controllers we don't want food
inspections we don't want any of that
kind of [__]
but they also they also want to support
Putin
they want Putin to take Ukraine so
that's very important that we shut down
the government not fund Ukraine
in light of it so that way Putin can win
I mean this is what Charlie Kirk and
others are saying and literally they're
saying hold the line hold the line here
here um here you go
shut down the Border shut down the
regime on 9 30. let's watch here's a
video
um in Eagle Pass and I I don't know if
this is actually a video so I'm not even
really gonna show it but he posts the
video it says a video from Eagle Pass
Texas today tens of thousands of
unbetted unknown male illegals are
simply walking into America like they
own the place this is dangerous this is
an invasion this is evil Joe Biden is a
traitor my orcas is a Trader there's no
bipartisan deal to broker shut down the
Border shut down the regime on 9 30.
they want the government shut down
not only this this isn't just the
Congress people and and a few Maga
lunatics in the House of Representatives
Trump wants it shut down
Trump is ordering it to be shut down I'm
not kidding you he [__] posted it
here let me show you and let me show you
and they're bragging about it they're
bragging about it here it is
a very important deadline is approaching
at the end of the month republicans in
Congress can and must defund all aspects
of crooked Joe Biden's weaponized
government that refuses closes the
border and treats half the country as
enemies of the state because they are
this is also the last chance to defund
these political prosecutions against me
and other Patriots we failed on the debt
limit but they must not fail now use the
power of the first defund the country
our excuse me defend the country but
that's really what he means isn't it is
defund the country
that's really what he means
and he's ordering House Republicans to
do that
literally
he's ordering them and they're listening
and saying we're gonna listen to his
orders write out loud here's Matt gatz
Trump opposes the continuing resolution
Hold the Line
close the government for Trump because
he says to close it now let me ask you
something
maybe I'm just way off my rocker here
when I say that they
will not reopen this government without
the say so of Donald Trump
tell me I'm wrong
go ahead try it
he literally is the traitor of the house
Kevin McCarthy holds the speakership is
the office but he's a puppet of the
traitor of the house Donald Jessica
Trump
and it's no clear now than ever
and House Republicans are not interested
in governing at all and the reason why
is because they're traitors to our
country our Constitution and our fellow
Americans
and I'm going to show you more of this
crazy [__] when we come right back right
after this
we'll be right back Mark
this is the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
I got some very exciting news for a
friend of ours here at the show Dr
Rachel binikoffer
missing the other day and I miss this
but I noticed it yesterday
she got her first copy of Hit Em where
it hurts
look coming out soon you can pre-order
it
[Music]
if the moderators would put her link
tree in the chat so everyone can go
check out Rachel bidikoffers pre-order I
want to show the um I want to show the
picture she posted
on social media of the book so you guys
can see the book here if I can
get my
my computer to work there we go there's
Rachel benicoffer with her book
Rachel Coffer with Aaron Murphy hit him
where it hurts so go pre-order that book
The pre-orders are available now we can
get the um her link tree in the chat
there my friend
my great friend and the best political
strategist I know political scientist Dr
Rachel bidikoffer her book hit him
wearing hers listen
I believe that one day we're going to be
able to brag
about this book
we're going to be able to brag about
this book that that Rachel
uh wrote with the help of Aaron Murphy
and this this book is how we're going to
brag about it or it's going to be like
this is the book that gave us
the direction and the road map to save
our democracy
I really believe that and I can't wait
to get a to get a copy so soon so I can
start thumbing through it
um I'm hoping I'm hoping I can I'm
hoping I can get my hands on an early
copy and then have Rachel on so go
pre-order
Dr Rachel bidikoffers
book let me see if I can get her her
link tree here for for everyone
I'll put it in the chat
uh there it is
hoppy here it is Dr Rachel whitakoffer
great great friend to the show there's
our link tree there well maybe nope
that's not it
oh boy here you go here I'll try again
I'll try again I'll try again
there we go there's a link tree
or you can go to you can go to like
Twitter wherever you can find Dr Rachel
bittickoffer and find that
well yeah I'm
I'm going to make sure that everyone
knows who who has that book and get that
book in their hands and the reason why
is because we still have people out
there saying this kind of [__] at Trump
rallies now Trump went to Iowa
and he spoke in this weird metal
building
and there's like I don't know 50 people
that showed up it was really pathetic I
don't know if you saw pictures of this
maybe I'll pull them up I don't even
know if it's worth pulling them up to be
honest with you to show you the tens of
people that showed up to listen to him
puke up [__] out of his mouth in Iowa
but here's one of the here's one of the
um
the Iowans that showed up to listen to
Donald Trump lie to him
um
wild [__] that this guy says listen to
how he hates socialism but he loves it
this is what I was talking about earlier
take a listen I just had to purchase a
new car because I
a deer totaled my other one and
it just
everything the cost of everything is way
too high and insurance medical insurance
as well Medicaid well fortunately I'm on
Medicare so oh okay it helps out a lot
right there yeah better and so I've got
oh I got you
okay well socialism socialism socialism
right hmm kind of funny kind of funny
how you know we should support programs
in this country I don't know to help
people out to make sure that they don't
have to spend money on one thing so they
can I don't know spending on another
Maybe
honestly
you know
a lot of people think that
our problem is education in this country
and it is it is education
but it's not our overall education
system really if you think about it it's
more rule Red State education see that's
the problem is that states really have a
lot of control over their education
system the public education system the
local government and the school boards
have a lot of say and a lot of power
over the education system in those
communities and what do you think these
education systems are like in these red
areas that these Republicans are running
huh
what do you think they're like
do you think you think the same
Republicans who want to shut down the
government because they want to protect
Trump
because he's being prosecuted for crimes
that he committed 91 charges by the way
from a grant from four different grand
juries
you think those same that same party
wants to wants to do a totally different
serious work
inside of school boards inside
communities for public education you
think so hmm kind of funny maybe maybe
this will maybe this will Enlighten you
too this lady whoo boy I would love to
see where she went to school but what is
Trump under his policies how did it
benefit your life
are you working retired I mean I'm
disabled I have a oh oh she's disabled
okay that may that that makes sense a
lot of Americans are disabled it's a
legitimate thing a lot of folks are
disabled let's hear how president Trump
helped her with her socialist disability
safety net that we have in this country
that is available for folks when they
become disabled like her let's hear
broken plate in my bag
and uh it really bummed me because
during covet I was supposed to get my
third surgery and have it fixed and when
the doctor a very big specialist went to
fix it he said where's your Medicaid
so what do you mean where's my Medicaid
well they took by Medicaid
so whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa wait a
second during coven was that 2020
it feels like someone someone was
president in 2020 that that man
and they took away her Medicaid now he
asked her the question do you you
remember the question he asked let me go
back let me go back let me let me see if
I don't think she remembers it let me go
back and see what what his question was
let's listen hey what is Trump under his
policies how did it benefit your life oh
okay how did it benefit your life
so it benefited her life by Medicaid
being taken away from her so she
couldn't receive the third back surgery
that she needed on her disc because
she's disabled yay yay vote for Trump
what that is the actual [__] opposite
of what did Trump do to better your life
the [__] absolute opposite
opposite
what did Trump do to help you and she's
like well actually actually that
[__]
he made it to where I couldn't get a
third surgery on my back because him and
Republicans took away my Medicaid
and um and then and you know
that was really awesome and stuff
let's hear it again I'm not kidding you
this is what she's saying he asked let's
watch it back Marjorie Taylor Green's uh
uh Beetle to juice
is gonna ask her in this question listen
to this again this is [__] incredible
hey what is Trump under his policies how
did it benefit your life
are you work you're retired I mean I'm
disabled I have a broken plate in my
back
and uh it really bummed me because
during covet I was supposed to get my
third surgery and have it fixed and when
the doctor a very big specialist went to
fix it he said where's your Medicaid
so what do you mean worse by Medicaid
well they took my Medicaid
so I'm coming up here hoping I'm getting
the surgery done
what the Trump rally
they have back surgeons
at the Trump rally kind of like a
socialist kind of thing huh I don't know
what the [__] she's talking about coming
up here I guess coming up there to to
vote for Trump so he'll take more
Medical Health Care away from her I mean
that's what Republicans want to do they
definitely don't want women to have
health care I don't know if she heard
but God damn they damn they don't want
women to be in the military they don't
want women to vote they don't want women
to have health care
I mean these are things that Republicans
don't want women to do
and they probably don't want them to
have back surgery especially on the on
the dull in the back of the taxpayer you
[__] freeloader
now here's the here's the actual truth
of this clip because I'm mocking it you
know but the sad part is is this lady is
probably actually disabled
she probably has some really severe back
problems
and it's probably because she worked her
ass off for no [__] pay for God knows
how long in this country
and no one no one that that she [__]
that she elected represented her in a
way that would make sure
that would make sure that she had decent
[__] pay
for the job that she had decent decent
medical leave
vacation leave so that she didn't
[__] throw at her back right and
become disabled
because she blew at her back because
again I I'm almost betting that this
that this lady
probably worked in a job that was just
absolute [__] pay and the worst [__]
work he could possibly have
I don't know if you know this but in a
lot of rural areas that's a lot of the
[__] jobs
you don't get paid worth of [__] and you
work your goddamn back off
and and this lady is so [__]
manipulated
by these Republican Nazis
that she goes to a rally to support a
person who she said in her own words
just now
what did Trump do to you for you and
she's like they took away my Medicaid
this this should [__] piss you off it
should [__] piss you off more than
anything else then I'll show you today
is that these [__] [__] boxes
like Trump and the House Republicans and
Kevin McCarthy and these lying sacks of
[__] for years Mitch McConnell Grover
norquist
Rush Limbaugh Sean Hannity Fox News all
these [__]
have absolutely convinced this person
that because she has white skin and
she's Superior
and that she's a Christian
just vote for Republican because they
definitely are not doing the things that
they're doing to you after you vote for
them it's the same thing like in all
these red States they're so [__]
upset that the that inflation High and
the state economy is bad and blah blah
blah they keep yacking and yakking and
these State these Republican state
houses about how it's Joe Biden's fault
that their state sucks Joe Biden's been
president for two years
you [__] in these red states
have been running these red States for
decades decades
and you're now all of a sudden
education is [__] because of Biden the
economy's [__] because of Biden
everything's woke because of Biden
maybe it maybe you should [__] get a
mirror right
maybe you should get a mirror and
understand that this lady's problems is
caused because she's voting for
republicans
her plight
her plight that she's talked because it
is true I I actually I I actually I'm I
genuinely believe this lady that she has
back problems
I I don't know how many people I've met
in rural communities that absolutely
have the worst worst [__] access to
health care and it's because they vote
for Republicans because Republicans
don't want to give them access to health
care so they can blame the government oh
man government doesn't know how to run
Health Care even though it's them who
doesn't know how to run Health Care [__]
there's there's dozens and slews of
rural hospitals in Missouri that that
went away gone poof empty don't exist
anymore
because Republicans wouldn't accept
Federal money from the ACA to go to
those rural communities to make sure
that those people in those communities
had Access to Health Care
and they were like oh ACA it's all the
aca's fault no it's not the aca's fault
it's your fault you didn't take the
money to fund those [__] hospitals
but they do this all the time
and they [__] manipulate these people
that's what the [__] they do
okay that is how the minority ideology
in this country has one wide swaths of
power in this country even though the
majority of this country doesn't believe
in that [__] this lady this lady
doesn't believe this [__]
if she really sat down and talked to
Brian Glenn here and Marjorie Taylor
green his his Beetle juicer right
I guess that's what we're calling it now
BJ beetlejuicer I don't know
is that zero days can we put zero days
on the counter okay
anyways
I bet if this lady actually sat down and
asked if you were able to give her some
questions that she could ask and
understand
to Brian Glenn and Marjorie Taylor green
his beetlejuicer she would she would
[__] hate them at the end of the
questions [__] hate them because she
would realize that these people are
actually doing to her what her plight is
right in her back she's disabled because
of her back my guess is that this lady
doesn't have any money either
like she relies completely on every
single [__] penny that she is given
by disability
government money safety net which I'm I
say that we should it should probably be
more honestly this lady could probably
use more government assistance if you
want to know the honest truth and I'm
sure that I'm sure that you out there
the pro-democracy Coalition what you
want to do is be for your fellow
countrymen when they have hardship
that's what I want I want a safety net
that every American doesn't have to go
broke because of a medical bill
this lady should not have to go [__]
broke because she needs a goddamn back
surgery because she worked her ass off
when she was younger in a [__] job for
[__] pay
to make some other [__] rich
in this country
okay
I'm telling you
telling you
we are right around the corner
we cannot give up we cannot stop
engaging in our democracy because folks
if this lady really knew the truth
if this lady knew the truth she would be
there protesting that [__]
she would be there saying what and you I
don't [__] like anything that
[__] did he took away my [__]
Medicaid
I voted in Republicans and they did the
opposite of what they said they were
going to do to for me they always do
they're going to shut down the
government they were elected to keep the
government open just like she voted for
Trump for the thing that she needed
which was her health care and her back
fixed
foreign
it doesn't make much sense is it
disheartening I have so [__] lutely
it's disheartening
because again
this lady probably worked her ass off
and worked her back off if you want to
know the literal sense
and she probably needs these surgeries
but she'll go broke
over that medical bill she probably
doesn't even have enough money to get to
the hospital to go to the doctor's
appointments let alone the [__]
surgery itself
and no American none none of them
including her
should go [__] broke because of a
medical bill
not one of us should go [__] broke
because of it
there's no reason for it in this country
we have the ability to have the
healthcare infrastructure we have the
[__] money
there's no way you can convince me but
taking away just a tiny fraction of the
GDP away from the one percent in this
country to pay to make sure no one goes
broke because of a medical bill
is somehow going to affect
the [__] yacht they're going to buy
to get the tax break and that's the
other thing we could stop giving them
[__] tax breaks for yachts and
private jets and start taxing them and
get this lady a [__] surgery for
crying out loud
now if you put it in that way to this
lady
if you put it in that way to this lady
maybe just maybe maybe just maybe maybe
just maybe
the light bulb would come on maybe just
just for a second just just like maybe
just for a second
because I bet if you said it the way I
just said it not well we had Universe
Healthcare we we really we elected
Democratic socialists and and and and
and lefties in this country and we get
free health care government Healthcare
if you say [__] like that she's gonna
she's gonna be like that's social
socialism and Democrats are demons
no
you got to meet people where they are
this lady needs a [__] back surgery
or did need a back surgery she can't
afford it without a safety net which she
shouldn't have to have
to go completely broke over a medical
bill
even as ridiculous as she is and as
backwards as her thinking is
and how deluded she is
this woman still does not deserve to go
broke because of a medical bill
but Republicans use her because you know
what they think they're like you know
what we'll make people go broke because
of a medical bill and we'll make them
think it's the government's fault baby
we'll make a biggest government's fault
oh yeah that's what we'll do we'll shut
down the government we'll make them
think all there all their all their
hardship is because of the big bad
government and you know what will trick
them to think
that they aren't the government that
they're not the ones who actually are
like this that there's some sort of deep
secret deep state that controls
everything even though we're actually
the ones that control everything
but we don't want them to know that we
don't want the masses to know that they
actually can vote us out
because if they know that oh my God they
would [__] boy they'd vote us out in
a heartbeat
so we really should probably use things
like religion and abortion
you know really hot button issues
and we can cause them to be hot button
issues you know
that way we can make these people
believe that the government actually
isn't actually them it's their enemy you
see
you see how that works
that's why I say all the time the
narrative needs to shift
and it needs to shift that we the people
are the government It Is Us in a
democratic constitutional republic we
are the government we elect people to go
represent us in the government and
fulfill those obligations to their
constituents us the people the
government
It Is Us
stop acting like there's some [__]
scary ass government somewhere that's
going to come get you
that's all horseshit there's no [__] it
there's no deep state
there there's a swamp it's the
Republicans
I don't know if you noticed that but the
swamp is the party that wants to kill
democracy with democracy
so
when you see a clip like this and I know
again I I'm I'm mocking her because it's
stupidity oh my God it's the dumbest
stupidest thing that he asked her
what Trump did for her and she literally
told him what Trump did was bad
and she's there to support him and he's
like yeah that's that's a great story
that doesn't feed into the narrative at
all but can you believe the people
watching this trash
are like oh my god did you hear what the
Democrats did to her during when
President Trump
was the president during the the the
fake coveted pandemic thing
and she needs that back surgery
she's disabled but we hate socialism and
we need to get rid of Medicare Medicaid
because that's just that's just
socialist Democratic programs but she
needs it but she doesn't I don't know
I know it doesn't make sense
I know it doesn't and it and it feels
like it should make sense right to her
to you or anyone else
but we literally are living it
in WrestleMania in real life
the intersection
of WrestleMania and real life
and these people have coupled
entertainment with politics
and lies with politics
it's incredible the cognitive dissidents
it's incredible
and even even what you would think is
smart people can't even see it I'm gonna
let me show you this clip you talk about
some stupidity here and and yesterday
this happened in the Merit Garland
hearing
when he was being asked about Hunter
Biden Hunter Biden Hunter Biden Hunter
Biden Hunter Biden Hunter Biden over and
over and over and over again
and he continued to say look I'm not in
charge of the hunter by investigation I
made David Weiss the special counsel he
is he's a trump appointee he was
actually appointed by Trump to
investigate Hunter Biden and we allowed
him to continue to do that which we
probably shouldn't have but we did
because we didn't want it to look
political because you would say it
looked political and then the country
would kind of buy that it was political
but it's not really
when really the political weaponization
of government is y'all
not us
but Andy Biggs steps in it I mean just
[__] steps in it watch this this is
[__] wild stuff watch how he
describes
a document's case
right
and it confuses Merrick Garland but the
confusion
is [__] hilarious watch this I just
want to know is it consistent to call
people and where you know that they've
got boxes of information or you suspect
they have boxes of information that's
why you got the warrant that's why
you're going to go look
and you give them a heads up so they can
move those boxes of information would
that be consistent with doj policy just
who is who is he describe who do you
think he thinks he's describing
Biggs here who do you think he's
describing I I mean Garland thinks one
thing I mean here watch what Garland
says watch it's gonna say again you're
asking me actually to comment about
allegations in a particular case about
no I'm not no I'm not I'm asking you is
that consistent with your overall policy
forget forget Delaware and what they did
and that they actually did that whoa
Delaware wait wait wait wait Delaware
whoa whoa whoa whoa wait a second hang
on hang on hang on hang on hang on
Andy Biggs here is is not talking about
the obvious
which is the person who's been indicted
on Espionage and obstruction of justice
okay
he's talking about the person
who has a special counsel assigned to
the case that has not been indicted and
he's literally he literally described
the Trump case line by line and how bad
it is
and he projected it onto Joe Biden watch
what Merrick garland does here it's
[__] it's funny just talk about
generic policy sorry I thought you were
asking about Mar-A-Lago I I may not have
understood that oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah
what in the actual [__] just happened
are you kidding me
think about this for a second so Andy
Biggs who's supposed to be a congressman
supposed to be he's not
this guy is not qualified to be a member
of Congress it is [__] more clear
right now in this moment in that [__]
37 second clip that Andy Biggs is not
qualified to ask anyone questions in a
Committee hearing at all
he literally described the Trump
documents case line by line
by line
I when I first watched the clip I
thought he was I thought he was talking
about Trump when he said that [__] I'm
like whoa that's kind of weird why why
would Andy Biggs be describing the Trump
documents case as a crime
but that's because he's lying and he's
projecting because he says Delaware
right he doesn't say Biden or Hunter he
says Delaware and what he meant what he
meant is he meant the boxes that were
next to Joe Biden's Corvette in the
garage
that's what he and which is all the
facts that he laid out
for describing the case against whoever
that he's describing is the Trump case
none of those facts Joe Biden didn't
move the boxes they didn't they didn't
have to get a [__] criminal warrant
when they found out when the when
Biden's lawyers found that there was
documents in the house they invited
they invited the FBA and Nara to come
look in the house that's what they did
Nara and the doj didn't have to go get a
criminal warrant
based on the Espionage Act and
obstruction of justice
they didn't have to do that those are
facts in the Trump case and that's why
Garland is confused here he's like whoa
what Delaware what the I thought you
were talking about Trump
because those are the facts in the Trump
case not in the Biden case
and you're wondering and you're still
wondering
how the woman in Iowa
is convinced that Trump taking away
Republicans taking away Medicaid taking
away her Medicaid
is and her not being able to get a back
surgery during the pandemic is Trump
helping her because that's what Brian
Glenn asked
and you're wondering how that's possible
here is a [__] sitting United States
congressperson Andy Biggs
Andy Biggs is not dumb
he seems ignorant but he's not dumb
but here he is describing in detail the
Trump case not the Biden case
and he doesn't even note it until the
very end when Merrick Garland is
legitimately confused
and then he says la di da
and the reason why he says Lottie da at
the end is because he had his ass handed
to him by confusion
mayor Garland wasn't being snotty
Merrick Garland was legitimately
confused
whoo
but this is the GOP
folks you can't make this [__] up okay
let's um let's see if we can get another
clip uh from
um a hearing yesterday I believe I have
another one here
I thought I did that I wanted to show
maybe not
I got so many clips that I want to show
oh here's one
um I didn't
um
someone asked who
the mask
why is George Santos questioning Carlin
I don't know I think it's George Santos
don't you I would think it is yeah so
there's that
can you believe can you believe they
chose
Harriet Hagman
over Liz Cheney I mean I know Liz Cheney
fan you know this
like
I'd rather have the worst Democrat in
the history of ever in charge of
something than Liz Cheney that's right I
said it a lot of people don't like that
I say that because Liz Cheney is some
kind of hero because January 6 select
committee she did the bare minimum
actually she did not do the bare minimum
it took her 190 days did you know this
190 days
to go to the floor of the house to say
on record that Trump lost
190 days after the election folks who
but they chose her Hagman over oh oh yep
I found it I found it I found it I found
it I found the clip
oh you're gonna like this one the
traitor Scott Perry this is a great clip
by the way
because when met with common sense
Scott Perry Falls flat watch this these
are not Market forces
this is the government funding the
destruction of our own automotive
industry and I hope you know that
approximately two-thirds of EV owners
make over a hundred thousand dollars a
year my bosses don't make that
foreign
how you justify forcing my constituents
to pay for EVS and EV infrastructure for
Coastal Elites and wealthy people but
somehow you do well I need to point out
that wealthy people were specifically
excluded from the inflation reduction
act well I just gave you the number do
you dispute that two-thirds of VV owners
are owned by people over a hundred
thousand that make over a hundred
thousands yeah the first TVs of course
were you dispute that I know but that
number's going down those are the facts
it doesn't matter if they're going down
oh oh those are the facts so so Scott
Perry likes the facts when the facts
shoot him but the fact is is that he's
like they may be going down so he's
admitting that Pete bootage is right
that that the facts are that the cost of
vehicles and the reason why the cost of
vehicles are going down is because this
is how this [__] works
Scott Perry claiming to probably be a
free market capitalist doesn't
understand that
he doesn't understand that
but let's continue and I know this is
jumping back to the EV thing but I had
to show this clip with Pete bootage
because he [__] owns Scott Berry here
let's watch that I represent I can't
afford them today sir why were you
against cutting their costs all these
factors I'm not against cutting the cost
the market should do it but you want the
the government you want my taxpayers to
pay to cut the cost which isn't cutting
the cost of subsidizing effectively
Congressman if you were with all these
factors
all these factors
at a loss that the cost of the as my as
my car okay first off first off scott
Perry is a horrible Congress person and
again
when you are in Congress and you're the
congressperson and you're questioning a
witness no matter who it is okay it is
your time it is the Congress person's
time in that Committee hearing
Scott Perry as the chairman here doesn't
even know that he can say I reclaim my
time
I reclaim my time
it is my time and Pete bootage is trying
to get words in edgewise which speed
Buddha judge is really good at it
because people like Scott Perry are
really stupid at this Jim Jordan's
really dumb at this too James Comer
they're idiots they don't know how to
run a [__] Committee hearing they
have no idea about the rules they really
don't know
they don't know
because if Scott Perry had any kind of
sense to him which he doesn't he doesn't
this is why he tried to overthrow our
government
by being a participant in the plot to
with the Cheeto dust kangaroo coup
and we know he's trying to hide that
because he's trying to hide his cell
phone conversations that he had about
the coup and it appears that the courts
may let him hide those conversations
that he had about the coup plot and how
he was helping
right
but Scott Perry here could do what any
congressperson can do when they're in a
committee
be civil
might be difficult for a Republican
and know the rules and the rules are is
at the time of Scott Perry's not Pete
bootages it's not as much as I'd like
for it to be Pete's
it's not mayor Pete's
it's Scott Perry's time he's Congress
person he's the one that's elected by us
regardless of how you like how that
sounds
they have no [__] clue
how the rules work in their committees
and he's the chairman
why is it so [__] surprising then
that Scott Perry doesn't know how
subsidies work
he has no [__] clue how subsidies
work that he would know
that the subsidies that are given to the
people in his district who can't afford
a [__] EV aren't paid for by them
it's paid for by the collective tax
system which should be a progressive tax
system which means we should tax people
who make more money to give it to make
sure that people who can't afford EVS
can't afford EVS in Scott Perry's
District I don't know if he knows that's
how substitution works
probably not he doesn't even know how to
run a [__] Committee hearing so it
wouldn't be surprising to me but let's
see if he knows that colleague on the
other side the gas guzzling pickup truck
is higher now to pay for the loss as you
kill your Administration and you
particular kill the Auto industry and
I'll remind you in 2008 after a
financial crisis the federal government
bailed out this industry so while you're
here today will you commit and will you
pledge to oppose any effort to bail out
the Auto industry after you force it
into bankruptcy again will you do that
today sir
so Scott Perry here believes that
because there is more of a demand for
EVS on the market that the car
manufacturers are being haranged
to make EVS by Pete Buddha judge just
the last two years right this is oh my
God this is Chevrolet Ford and Chrysler
are are being bullied just the last two
years to manufacture EVS okay
I don't know Scott Perry obviously does
not know how subsidies work he obviously
does not know how to run a Committee
hearing so he probably doesn't know how
how car manufacturing and car
development Works automobile development
Works he doesn't know that when you buy
a 2023
XYZ Chevrolet and it's a brand new model
that brand new model took years to
develop to get to the market
not months
Scott Perry not months years to develop
not to mention a brand new kind of
automobile in an EV to get it to Market
it's taken decades
you idiot
now it's not surprising again that Scott
Perry does not know how subsidies work
he does not understand how how to run a
Committee hearing or how a Committee
hearing works when he's the Congress
person asking the questions
it really is not or should not be
surprising that he has no clue
that it takes a hell of a lot more than
a couple months for an automobile
manufacturer to develop a vehicle to
bring to Market
these people are [__] dumb let's keep
with the stupidity though because it's
beautiful Congressman I got started in
politics when I guess the answer is no I
yield Factory was at risk of being shut
down because an elected official in my
state tried to block the administration
from saving Chrysler I got involved and
stood with the UAW to save those jobs
and I'll always be with auto jobs being
preserved
again Scott Perry doesn't know how to
run a committee meeting he's trying to
figure out how well who's next what's
next what what the rules are who's got
time because Scott Perry doesn't got the
time to know what his [__] job is it
ain't no wonder they have to shut down
the [__] government because they
don't know even how to run a goddamn
Committee hearing let alone the [__]
government let's keep going thank you Mr
secretary would you like to finish your
statement
sure thank you and I'll try to be as
concise as I can okay so what just
happened here is this congressperson I'm
not sure exactly who it is she is off
screen but this Congress person
understands it's her time she
understands it she's a Democrat by the
way
she understands how the committee works
and the rules so now it's her time so
what she's doing is she's handing her
time for Pete boo to judge to finish his
statement
so what's happening here go ahead and
take a listen
there are some people who I suppose
believe there should be no subsidies for
anything involving transportation and I
assume in the spirit of philosophical
consistency they would be against
subsidizing oil and gas as well as being
against subsidizing Americans being able
to afford an EV
there are others who believe that we
should force Americans to be in the
technology of the past forever
and then there's this Administration
which recognizes that the world is
moving to EVS with or without us and
those EVS are either going to be made by
Chinese workers or they're going to be
made by American workers and we respect
the UAW standing up at the dawn of a new
chapter in the automotive industry that
created my hometown
to make sure that those are not just
American jobs but good paying American
jobs
well God damn what a traitor
what a traitor that Pete booty judge is
American jobs are you listening to what
he's saying American jobs in Indiana
you son of a [__]
oh my God I just I can't explain to you
how far we are behind in messaging
people the judge does such a good job at
com and combating the stupidity uh Pete
Buda judge is very good at it he's not
quite the fetterman brand but he's
getting there
he's getting there
fetterman's another one that could clap
back
easily
swiftly
and break down the stupidity in just a
few sentences
this movement is coming folks
this [__] stupid idea that liberalism
is weak
it's just a [__] it's just a [__]
line actually you know it might be it
might be one of the big lies there's a
lot of big lies in this country there's
a lot of big lies one of them the big
lie
one of them is a big lie that Trump
one that's a huge lie
even a bigger lie is that Trump is
popular
he's not
don't believe it just because there's a
few [__] cult members that show up
when he arrives at God knows where for
God knows what reason
just because there's when he throws
pizzas at him they're like yeah I love
you and then he signs their boobs I'm
not [__] you he signed a lady's
boobs in Iowa
[__] family Christian Family Values
right there I'm I don't I actually don't
have a problem with it if she wants her
boobs signed and he wants to sign him
hey more power to you just the same way
I feel about Lauren bobert juice and the
beetle in Denver I whatever you want to
do honestly that's up to you and
Americans can make their decision
whether they like that or not and
honestly I think Americans in Colorado
and her constituents should make the
decision rather they think her juicing
the beetle in the Denver theater is
disqualifying for her to be a
congressperson they should make that
decision but she's welcome to do that if
it's consensual why not hell you know
everyone's like oh it's so offensive
it's so offensive that they were groping
each other come on PDA isn't that
offensive I mean it's not they weren't
getting naked okay
they they apparently they've been in sex
with each other for a while they're all
sexed up they were probably drunk and
high in the theater which you know I'm
not going to claim that I've never went
into a theater not inebriated before
because I certainly have
so I'm not gonna sit here and be like oh
oh she's she shouldn't do that when I've
done it I've done it I go I get high and
I go watch a movie at a theater it's
better that way if you want to know the
honest truth you should try it actually
I mean try not to you know
get caught committing crimes because
you're you know doing sexual acts in a
theater I'm not saying that but what I'm
saying is is that there's so many
disqualifying things about Republicans
one here with Scott Perry in this
exchange with Pete Buddha judges not
only did Scott Perry shouldn't be a
congressman he should not be a chairman
he doesn't know how committee he doesn't
know how the committee hearings work he
doesn't know the [__] rules he
doesn't know how subsidies work no
[__] clue how subsidies work
he doesn't know he's sitting here
advocating oh man well here's the thing
is if if you're going to give subsidies
it better benefit my constituents oh so
like the subsidies that are given to to
corporate gas and oil companies like
those subsidies
maybe Scott Perry hasn't heard
maybe he hasn't heard but our government
gives our taxpayers dollars to oil
companies did you know that Scott Perry
and they're called subsidies
but why why isn't those subsidies going
directly to Scott Perry's constituents
so they can afford gasoline vehicles why
are they going
to the oil company
and really the longer the short of it is
with with with any of this uh automotive
industry stuff obviously one of the
biggest motivations to keep the
automotive industry in this country is
for real actual good paying a career
level jobs for Americans
America I mean our our country was built
on automobiles like highways
now
as technology changes is it is it likely
that we'll move towards EVs and more
likely that we should move towards more
public transportation we have technology
in this country
that we are not taking advantage of that
they are wildly wildly out competing Us
in other countries in the world
some of them the ones that Republicans
seem to love and hate they hate when
Joe Biden Hunter Biden took money from
China
what they don't know is some of these
countries all around the world are miles
ahead of us
when it comes to not just reducing
emissions
to help I don't know the error being
clean so we can [__] breathe in the
future
but also also making it way more
efficient and way more cost efficient
for public transportation
way more efficient
but you can't you can't even have a
conversation with these [__] [__]
about a technology that is coming
whether they like it or not like Pete
butterjud says here electric vehicles
they want to be stuck in the past on
everything [__] and everything
and Scott Perry not realizing here in
this moment
that when he's advocating for for
gasoline vehicles that he's advocating
for subsidies taxpayer dollars to go to
corporations
the oil companies yet he has a problem
when he has a problem when a subsidy
goes to an actual an American to buy a
car
no problem with corporations getting
sepsi you follow that well he may not
know that
[Laughter]
he loves subsidies again remember what I
said earlier I want my rich white
welfare
so that way you don't get your poor
Brown welfare that's the sentiment there
Scott Perry's like whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa you're telling me you're going to
give subsidies to poor people the Poor's
and not the rich
CEOs and the fat cats that own the oil
companies come on that seems backwards
that's what Scott Perry's thinking there
so take it for what it's worth
but when it comes to Republicans and
they're met
with common sense they fall flat
every single
time
every one of them
they fall flat every single time I want
to show you
um speaking of falling flat
Rachel posted this article from Apple
news Dr Rachel bittickoffer here and but
it's about Lynn wood do you guys
remember Linwood doesn't he look like
Jim Jones
I I didn't realize until this morning
when I saw this picture
that he looks so much like Jim Jones oh
my God
doesn't he am I wrong please tell me I'm
wrong
I mean Jim Jones dyed his hair like
Street black but if Jim Jones wouldn't
have dyed his hair black like that then
you know he would look like this in
pictures but Jim Jones you know he had a
problem with his self-image
as as most cult leaders do
and he had to dye his hair right
but the Linwood looks like Jim Jones
here
that was amazed but apparently Lynn wood
the former lawyer because he's not a
lawyer anymore from what I understand he
surrendered
his ability
um to be a lawyer in Georgia
and the reason why is because
they were going to take it away from him
if he didn't hand it over
but the former Maga lawyer Linwood is
cooperating with Georgia in the case
against Trump I could then Rachel points
it out here now we know why Linwood
avoided indictment now Lynn wood
is nuttier than a [__] squirrel turd
okay this guy's this guy I mean you
think like Mike Flynn says some crazy
[__]
or
or some of these that like Sydney Powell
says some crazy [__] Rudy Giuliani oh
[__]
that has to stand back in awe like you
know what
squirrel turds are probably jealous of
how [__] nutty Linwood is
way out there man he was on he was on a
tour talking about [__] religion and
God and he's the one it's crazy [__]
but now he's cooperating
with the with the Georgia
grand jury in the Georgia prosecutors
rap row rat row it seems like Trump
didn't pay enough attention to one of
his nutty lawyers
and his nutty lawyer probably thinks the
reason why he doesn't have the ability
to practice law and make money in that
market anymore
is because of trump
so get on Linwood for uh cooperating
ah I hope he gets a sweetheart deal down
there in a Georgia prison
I don't know maybe they'll eventually
indict these people maybe not
maybe maybe not okay let's see I had
some more Clips I want to show we're
running out of time here running low on
time
but you know that's how oh here here's
here's one I want to show uh yesterday
we we showed you the story about Ray
Epps remember the right wing was like
yeah this guy's a Fed remember that he's
a fad
and then like and then the feds are like
now we're gonna charge him he's not
actually a fed and the right wing is
like oh they're just charging because
they don't want us to know that he's a
Fed
but here's Ryan Reilly here he says raps
was not a confidential source for the
FBI DHS or any other agency before
during or after is the quote in the
January 6 attack a federal prosecutor
confirmed in court today
so these are facts that the federal
bronze eaters brought to court today
and he was not an informant or a
confidential source for the FBI DHS or
other agencies quote before during or
after
the January 6 attack so what they did is
they leveled an indictment against him
and he pled guilty
to a misdemeanor charge in that effort
to indict him he pled guilty to a
misdemeanor charge
hell
it is crazy
it is crazy that these that we even know
who rayaps is you know you understand
that it is crazy that we even know who
this is
but again it's Maga not knowing how you
know facts work
and how truth works that it's going to
come around and bite him in the ass
now my response to this of course I was
a little rude to Ryan I shouldn't be
rude to Ryan Ryan does good reporting
Ryan's not the problem here
Ryan Reilly is not the problem here Ryan
Reilly does a good some good reporting
on January 6th
um Insurrection if you want to know the
honest truth about that
um but I said hate to say it but no [__]
Sherlock
no [__] Sherlock he wasn't an informant
I told you that I told you that
yesterday before the federal prosecutors
confirmed it you know what else I told
you I told you Trump ordered the House
Republicans to shut down the government
and Bam
proves me right these things aren't hard
to see they aren't hard to know they
aren't hard to predict
they really aren't
these are just these are just things
that exist in the universe and if you
use what brain cells you have to rub
together you can see this I think that's
why you guys like coming here number one
because I point out stories in ways that
no one else will no one else would just
say it like you need to [__] say it
like when you're sitting in your living
room and you're watching the news or
you're watching the mainstream media and
they're telling you a story and you're
yelling at the TV because you're like
say this God damn it say it this way
right stop being such a [__] [__]
and say it this way you know what I mean
you know the feeling that you get
I know you do because I get the feeling
and then you come here because you're
like well he'll say it for me
he'll say it into a microphone for
thousands and tens of thousands of
people to listen
maybe we'll make some Headway here
so I get it that you come here for that
but you also come here because
you know these things you know these
things
you don't need someone else to tell you
or give you confirmation the media to
give you confirmation that Donald Trump
is controlling Kevin McCarthy there's
plenty of evidence out there to
understand what is happening in the
House of Representatives
all you need to do is go back in time
and look at a few of the [__] shows
that we did when we were covering
the speaker votes when Akeem Jeffries
the Democrat was getting the majority of
votes Time After Time After Time After
Time the problem is that's not how the
house rules work
it's not gonna work
so even if Akeem Jeffries was getting
more votes than Kevin McCarthy
he couldn't be the speaker
because you needed a certain amount of
votes to be the speaker not the majority
but the majority of majority of of the
house on almost every single vote wanted
Hakeem Jeffries
to be the house speaker
if you really think about it
but Kevin McCarthy became the house
speaker because he traded away his power
and his speakership to Donald Trump
I mean yeah of course he traded away to
the Republican members but the
Republican members that are in manga
that are controlled by Donald Trump
that is what happened
I knew it then
I knew it then that it was going to
happen
so it was easy to say then and I said it
that they would shut down the government
in September that's what I said
go back and look at it I said it over
and over they're going to shut down the
government in September
they're gonna do it
now I'll I'll be honest
Joe Biden and Democrats really swooped
in and [__] confused the [__] out of
Republicans well it's not hard because
they don't really understand how this
[__] Works they're so concerned about
[__] giving the fat cats all the
breaks and [__] their constituents
over to blame it on Democrats that
they're not they're not skilled enough
to understand how government works and
how policy works
so it's not surprising that Joe Biden
the Democrats schooled them on the debt
ceiling I doubt we're going to get that
on the government shutdown here
because Kevin McCarthy really doesn't
have that choice because of how Joe
Biden handed him his ass on the debt
ceiling and the Democrats handed the
House Republicans their ass on the debt
ceiling
but these things aren't hard to know I
don't need a crystal ball to know these
things you don't need a crystal ball to
know these things that's why you come
here
is because there's someone who's talking
[__] sanity
in a way that can talk to every single
person in this country
I'm not some [__] Elite I'm just
normal average person
just dude here talking on microphone the
way that you [__] feel about this
[__] in a cathartic way two hours a day
that's why you come here
and I'm happy to have your support
because without your support I could not
keep this microphone going I couldn't
keep the microphone on
we couldn't do it
so I appreciate it rather you whether
you're buying shots hypothetical shots
or real shots because I do spend some of
that money on shots I'm not gonna lie
support the show you're a member of the
patreon you're sending in venmo chats
let's check to see if we have any
whatever you're doing whether you're
you're linking your Prime account to
your Twitch account doing it that way
uh we do have we do have a couple super
chats here
um
Ty Ross says podcast podcast again thank
you Ty
um I'll put her up I'll put her up on
here she must be she's always watching
Ty's always Ty's always watching so I
appreciate um
I appreciate Ty and her support
you guys should support Ty as well
in her efforts
in this battle for the democracy so
thank you Ty podcast podcast
I appreciate it and then um let's see
here we got
we got one
from Mark let's see if we can pull this
one up
uh he says keep mocking them let's see
if I can
it's a little bit of a roundabout way to
get this going here on this thing but
he says here
keep mocking them Tony at work speaking
of action that works folk can send
postcards to voters and swing States
like critical races in Virginia yeah
they can
um you have turnoutpack.org
as an example of that
but uh what what you should also do
is you can and we can add this to the
list if you want
we can add this to the list of places
that the library democracy can look at
here's here's the uh
turnoutpack.org so thank you for the uh
the venmo super chant there mark
and Ty did we get any shots today
this is you know I know I'm taking time
here
um and I appreciate every single one of
you sticking around every single day and
next week I know it's Thursday and we're
not going to throw it a Gabe today
because he's out for the rest of the
week
um and I'm not sure about bonehead
tomorrow we're gonna work on that I
promise uh let's see we did we did Gary
Gary and and William
uh bought some shots so thank you Gary
and thank you William for the shots
thank you for the support and I'll give
shout outs there
and I appreciate every single one of you
coming here every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific for two full hours to keep
mocking them and keep pointing out these
things and one of the most significant
things you can take away from from
today's show is that clip of Brian Glenn
asking that lady what Trump did for her
and she described how Trump hurt her and
she's still in support of him
this is how backwards some of the people
in our country have been convinced to be
it's sad
that that lady deserves the surgery
she needs the surgery she's the same and
again she probably [__] worked her
back off
in some [__] shitty job with shitty
pay
we shouldn't exclude her
from from our social safety net in this
country we should encourage it
it's just we gotta get out there and we
gotta get the narrative in a place where
people know the truth and that's what
this show is about the [__] truth
ruin raw whether you'd like to hear it
or not
whether you like to hear it or not it's
about the truth so come tomorrow same
time same place same truth
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon